la dernière français otages français
encore détenus dans le monde sofi
petrona a été libérée comme l'annoncé à
la présidence du mali sur les réseaux
sociaux
elle c'est également le cas de soumaïla
cissé hautes personnalités maliennes est
la bordelaise sophie petrona avait été
enlevée le 24 décembre 2016 par des
hommes armés à gaza où elle dirigeait
depuis des années une organisation dada
l'enfance elle doit rencontrer emmanuel
macron qui est exprimé son immense
soulagement
je vous propose justement à d'écouter la
réaction de sophie petrona
[Musique]
parce qu'il favoriserait d'amis
c'était presque à 47 dans le lot fourni
on a mis de pression et c'est
heureusement ma plus grande joie
aujourd'hui et d'en savoir plus le
bonheur si ce temps à plus fous les
voilà alors pour le mali de prier
inclurait la démission les bénédictions
l'amérique
[Musique]
monde